now for a look at what's on newsstands
elliot page kicks off pride month as
esquire magazine's summer cover star the
new issue hits stands june 7th and
inside the halifax native reflects about
life since coming out as a transgender
man in december 2020 he writes quote i
can't overstate the biggest joy which is
really seeing yourself i know i look
different to others but to me i'm just
starting to look like myself well that's
due in part to elliot's newfound love of
working out which he hasn't been shy
about showing off on social media but
the results aren't just skin deep as
elliott writes the experience of being
in my body now is so different i'm
absolutely hooked the feeling of being
really engaged with it present pushing
it and getting stronger and gaining
weight it's thrilling i feel like a kid
doing it and his transformation will
also be on display in the third season
of the umbrella academy which will see
his character come out as trans what the
hell is cougar blitz essentially we're
screwed numerology q magazine samus gary
is opening up about his fiancee britney
spears and the miscarriage she recently
suffered the couple revealed their loss
in an instagram post in may but sam
tells the magazine they're staying
optimistic he says quote
we're positive about it it's something
that's happened to a lot of people and
one beautiful thing that i heard was
when the baby's ready it'll come
[Music]